we've got a pretty good idea which
movies will break the bank at the box
office in 2017 but there's more to the
year in movies than picking blockbusters
and super franchises
we've gone over the release schedule
taking a look at the prevailing trends
and come up with some theories about
what's happening at the Cineplex over
the next 12 months and beyond Rey's DNA
there are some bets that seemed safer
than others when it comes to Star Wars
Episode a well it's almost a guarantee
that they'll be at least one of these
lines thrown into the script I got a bad
feeling about this it's less clear which
if any more throwback character cameos
will come into the mix or if any of
those parentage issues left lingering
around the new kids on the galactic
block will finally be revealed with that
in mind we're protecting Star Wars fans
we'll learn more about Rey's lineage we
expect to see her training with Luke who
seems at least somewhat likely to be her
father
and don't forget Luke found out who his
dad was in the second installment of the
original trilogy so that would be good
timing logan 2.0 sorry will marine
fanatics but we're predicting Logan at
least as portrayed by Hugh Jackman is
not long for this world not only has it
healing ability been compromised by the
hand of time and Logan but the movies
trailer also seems to suggest the story
will serve as a full-length introduction
to his replacement Marvel Comics from
Laura Kinney aka x-23 is Logan's clone
daughter in the comics and she
ultimately assumes his mantle after his
death Logan seems to be on a suicide
mission to protect her in the trailer
and she smokes you with her sunglasses
after all so we wouldn't be surprised to
see him make the ultimate sacrifice
while x-23 comes into play for the new
mutant especially since that's exactly
what happened in the comics Stephen King
is king of all Mon American authors
perhaps none has had quite as much of an
impact on Hollywood as Stephen King
historian spawned dozens of movie
adaptation some of which he's liked
enough to make cameos in his library is
also scored several TV shows and
miniseries but until now some of these
most high concept stories have remained
firmly shown that changes with dark
towel which many kings fans consider the
backbone of the author's extended story
universe if it's big-screen adaptation
does well enough upon arrival later this
year we've definitely room for growth in
the series so prepare for a full-on
franchise if the box-office take is
right and if the upcoming adaptation of
King's it land - you can really get
ready to see filmmakers dive into the
King archives for even more bestsellers
that could be turned into potential
franchises sequels setbacks go ahead and
free up your calendar space on June 9
now because there's just no way World
War Z 2 is going to be in theaters that
day is scheduled even several months out
the film still hadn't even secured a
director and it's not the only delay
that's virtually inevitable this year's
James Cameron's Avatar - release date
for 2018 will probably get another nudge
back into 2019 if not further given the
lack of progress on the production front
so far well that and the fact that
Cameron wants to make is for avatar
sequels all at once meanwhile don't be
surprised if the Jumanji reboot slash
sequel gets kicked back again - because
it's notoriously had trouble finding
footing and it wouldn't necessarily be
shocking if Andy Serkis jungle book
origins ends up delayed or even scrapped
altogether in the wake of Disney's
critical and commercial success with its
own live-action Jungle Book relax kid no
need to get worked up okay
galactic expansion we learned anything
from the Disney's Pixar and Marvel
mergers it's that when Disney gets its
white-gloved boards into something
lucrative the studio is going to take
full and eager advantage
now be inexperienced ah that's already
the case with Disney Lucasfilm which
will undoubtedly start rolling out more
Star Wars sequels prequels and
standalone stories now that rogue one
has confirmed that the franchise is
viable even outside of the loop Leia Han
Solo story actions with the Han Solo
prequel on deck for 2018 and episode 9
scheduled to follow along in the summer
of 2019 we can probably count on the
Star Wars franchise to start looking
more like the MCU with two a year
announcements trickling into the release
schedule how that impacts the brand's
quality of course remains to be seen
fingers crossed
go Gamora since the superhero world
seems ever geared towards expanding its
franchise horizons Harley Quinn Wonder
Woman and Captain Marvel are all
preparing for diamond in the spotlight
but there's another character who might
be due for some solar screen time Gamora
from guardians of the Galaxy once volume
2 drops in May it's inevitably
impressive receipts will probably
justify giving some member of the
Teamsters or her own day in the Sun MCU
style one could easily argue that Gamora
is the ideal candidate for the job
considering her meeting family story
with donald's and nebula her radness
outside of being the object of star-lord
affection not to mention the fact that
she's currently starring in her own solo
comics title Gamora will no doubt true
to be key in The Avengers fight with Sun
off and if she were to get a standalone
story it means she could introduce the
badass all-girl warrior group the
Grayson the credentials are there and
Zoe Saldana has a proven record at the
box office
musicals are in again for all its faults
2016 did help to usher in a new
generation of movie musicals of the
successful broadcasts of grease live and
hairspray lies drummed up impressive
ratings from the small screen la-la-land
reminded everyone there is still a place
for this kind of good old-fashioned
entertainment in theaters the passing of
singing in the rain start Debbie
Reynolds may expire
of interest in classic sing-along cinema
or even in Spira studio or to take a
stab at a remake and Mary Poppins
returns with Emily Blunt and lin-manuel
Miranda should be a good boost thanks to
the la-la-land appreciation craze
Hollywood stars take note it might be
wise to schedule some singing less the
new kid Emma Stone will probably be the
award season sweetheart 2017 which means
someone might finally get the right idea
to put her and Jennifer Lawrence to get
up in a row G buddy comedy this year now
that pipe dream aside there will be
plenty of major breakouts in the months
to come
Daniel Kalu yard for example is bound to
the big time once he's twisty thriller
get out drops and details start to
emerge regarding his part in Marvel's
Black Panther count on him to capitalize
on rising interest in his town Alden
Ehrenreich likewise is a name that might
reach household status this year thanks
to his forthcoming turn as Han Solo in
the Star Wars been off Ehrenreich has an
impressive filmography under his belt
already with some small but memorable
roles but headlining as Han is a career
maker meanwhile actress sofia boutella
is also poised to have a major moment
this year after her work in the reboot
of the mummy and the coldest city
arrived in theaters the latter project
in particular seems promising as if the
Cold War spy thriller it gives her a
chance to steal scenes from some of the
industry's elite just like she did in
Star Trek beyond Fermi
like rip white Russia unfortunately this
year will bring us multiple films which
will again highlight the need for
studios to stop whitewashing movie cast
including the Great Wall and ghost in
the shell' both of which have already
attracted their share of controversy
Marvel's Doctor Strange somehow managed
to survive its own issues on that front
at least where the box office was
concerned but with these new pictures in
particular any enthusiasm seems likely
to be dampened by casting backlash
perhaps the conversations that results
whether the films are ultimately
successful or not will finally put an
end to Hollywood's unfortunate
whitewashing tradition once and for all
singers cry thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all
these cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]